ubermensch translates roughly to above  human or superman in english it is a  word that nietzsche uses to illustrate  his idea of how man can transcend his  current state the ubermensch is an ideal  it is an archetype that we can look up  to in order to navigate ourselves better  in the moral and social landscape niches  is the current state of man as a  transition he understands that if we  don't sacrifice ourselves to the extent  that we pursue our downfall and  perishing there will never be an  ubermensch he obviously talks in  metaphorical terms but he wants to make  noise in order to be heard we need to  sacrifice all the things that are  holding us back and limit our potential  things that we preserve because of fear  and ignorance we do so because we dwell  in a place of hypnosis and homeostasis  only someone who makes noise can wake us  up from this state